-This morning on her show,
Megyn Kelly invited
a panel of guests
to discuss
whether or not it's racist
for white people to wear
blackface on Halloween.
Take a look.
-But what is racist?
-But --
-Because -- Because, truly,
you do get in trouble
if you are a white person who
puts on blackface on Halloween,
or a black person who puts on
white face for Halloween.
-Yes.
-Like, back when I was a kid,
that was okay.
There was a controversy on "The
Real Housewives of New York"
with Luann.
And she dressed as Diana Ross.
And she made her skin
look darker than it really is.
And people said that
that was racist.
And I don't know --
I thought, like,
who doesn't love Diana Ross?
She wants to look like
Diana Ross for one day,
I don't know how, like,
that got racist on Halloween.
-Now, commenting on the racially
charged issue of blackface
is not something
I'm comfortable doing.
-But I am!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
First of all,
I heard about this,
and when I went to watch it,
I started typing in,
"Megyn Kelly defends blackface."
It auto-filled "Megyn Kelly
defends Brett Kavanaugh,"
so I knew, no matter what, I was
about to watch a terrible video.
And I was right.
Megyn said,
"I don't know how blackface
is racist on Halloween."
[ Sighs ]
It's not racist on Halloween.
It's racist every day.
There is no magical day
where you can wear blackface
with no repercussions.
Unless all of your friends
are white,
and I'm guessing all of
Megyn Kelly's friends are white.
[ Light laughter ]
Speaking of a bunch
of white people, this panel.
White, white, white, white.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh, so very white.
How are you gonna have a bunch
of white people sit together
and figure out what's racist?
White people don't get to decide
what's racist.
If I punch you, I don't decide
if it hurts or not -- you do.
And it won't because
I'm not punching no white lady,
because I don't want
to go to jail.
[ Laughter ]
Megyn Kelly said, "Blackface
wasn't racist when I was a kid."
You're 47.
Racism wasn't invented
40 years ago.
40 years ago,
they were just getting
into the swing of it, baby.
[ Light laughter ]
Today, it's perfected.
You may think the meanest thing
I could do
is call Megyn Kelly's words
racist,
but, really,
the meanest thing I did
was tell everyone she's 47...
[ Light laughter ]
...which, if you round up,
is 50.
She's 50.
Tell everybody.
-Amber, that's ageist.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I'm kidding.
She's 60.
-Amber!
-What?
I'm 103.
I just look this good
'cause black don't crack.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Applause continues ]
Look, Megyn Kelly
asked a question,
and here's the answer --
blackface is racist
because it turns black people
into a costume
and divorces them
from their humanity.
We're people, not costumes.
But more importantly, it ignores
the severely racist context
in which blackface was
introduced into this country,
and actions don't exist
separate from their context.
[ Sighs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
I agree!
Megyn Kelly
issued an apologize later,
but she wouldn't
have had to do that
if she had invited a black
person into the conversation
in the first place.
But, honestly, you shouldn't
need a black panelist
to explain to you
[bleep] you should have figured
out 57 years ago.
-Amber!
-Whatever.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She's 75.
But for someone...
[ Laughter ]
...for someone with
a morning show, Megyn Kelly,
you sure are late as hell.
[ Audience ohhs ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, oh. Here she comes.
And there she goes.